welcome to your house Tom Christina
come over later from musu hey keep them
high in sight yo burn you wicked big
dude you got to lose some more weight
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah dirty we're back guys we're back we
just had to have our mu soup that was uh
that was really terrifying I was
actually okay without our shit drops and
yeah I don't know what to do yeah all
right that works make sure I'd go
retarded yeah that works
welcome to alive your mom's house yep
down here with all the snowbirds and
Jews there's one and you fucking Puerto
Rican there's been so many Puerto Ricans
Cubans Cuban yeah we couldn't go
swimming today though cuz your water is
contaminated did you guys know that yeah
you know when you're Puerto Rican you're
just bought Rican we went to the beach
today
yeah and they and we went to a the guy
at the hotel we're like can we get an
umbrella he's like yeah but you know you
can't get in the water what do you think
we're gonna do here man and I go why
can't we get in the water then he goes
this bacteria is real high and then I go
is that comment he goes up in here a few
years we've never heard before
I know and I'm like cool great I swam in
this yesterday I'm sure it's fine right
yes
yeah it just it just got here from the
ocean
yesterday was cool but today's all
shitty and bad I think we're gonna be
radioactive yeah terrified
this would be our last show yeah Thank
You Florida second we flew here
I know but make sure this is all working
though hold on a second so just to make
sure that okay that worked dirty and
disgusting yeah there we go
what's your pronoun okay you've been
calling me ma'am left and right I'm very
offended are you just because they asked
them in your woman
[Laughter]
or cuz they're doing your old woman how
dare you
well I don't nobody calls me sir they're
always like little boy so stupid I hate
being called ma'am someone called me
madam the other day and I really I liked
it though because I wasn't 7-eleven
buying hot cheetos and he was like there
you go madam
what dude why that is so offensive he
was big words that basically is a big
word and I was so like I felt super
fancy you know like okay I should cuz
you were a madam yes you feel like a
mistress like a fart monster yeah so
many people have gone to fart mistress
calm the site is crashed and and and
they're sending messages to my mother to
be the fart mistress and she's like I'm
not gonna do it she's like she's very
upset
but then she likes the flattery of the
messages I tried to get her on Conan I
did Conan a couple weeks ago yeah and
there you know they do a pre-interview
like what do you want to talk about and
you start telling them all and then I
was like can we talk about fart mistress
calm and his producer was like I'm
listening like what is it I told him and
he goes he thought it was hilarious and
then he goes I told Cohen and then maybe
we'll get to it I was like are you
fucking serious and he goes oh there I
go alright and I was the whole time I
was just anticipating him being like
tell me about fart mistress
well could can they they can say fart
now on TBS right cuz if you did the you
know the network version they won't even
let you know no just farting no stupid
now you'd go full farts you can go all
fart ha you were waiting the whole time
for him yeah I was sitting there in the
chair like
yeah and then he was like yeah we'll see
my guess that's like another place I was
like okay later yeah but I was really
excited
do you okay so you're - are we gonna
read her the emails people have been
sending a hundred percent yeah excited I
want to get her on video yeah at least
video her hearing them and maybe
processing the movement if you don't
know we bought that we paid for the
website at fart mistress calm and I told
my mom like will you fart on this
website she was like a hundred percent
no and I was like what if we can get you
money and she was like what kind of
money are you talking about and I told
her like a couple thousand dollars and
she goes I'm not a prostitute and I go
well what's your number and she goes
well cuz you also position it like this
is your gambling money because she
really like she loves them the hard cock
comes you know and yeah in fart louder
day also far louder Dale makes me laugh
everything yeah she loves the slots she
plays the slots there did you play real
it's like and she sucks she's a fucking
she's the cooler like she comes in when
you walk in and they're like I was gonna
lose
that's the cooler right there and but
she has advice for you so there's like
it's the person imagine the person
that's like I've been divorced nine
times giving you relationship with
rights like that you're like but you
suck at this and then she's like I know
I know I know she's like this machine
doesn't pay don't sit here and I'm like
but if you're saying it probably does
pay so you know what's so interesting is
they put the water bucket next to me so
weird
it's like they knew that I drink the
most water in the man that's some
bullshit right there yeah take your time
yeah you want to you want a bah-bah
nipple for that why are you putting the
mic I want them to hear it
but this is bullshit that this doesn't
dehydrate you doesn't do you believe in
that clap if you think coffee doesn't
dehydrate you psychos five psychos then
I'm so thirsty when I drink it it
doesn't dehydration shit so speaking of
shit since we've been here I just feel
like you guys should know that I haven't
really been browning as much I know
devastating news yeah and I think part I
think the problem is because we don't
have a bidet in the hotel we're staying
it's disgusting this is affecting your
going to the bathroom course why because
my asshole is a gun shy it knows it
knows that it can't relax and release
because there's no ample cleanup
provided I have to admit it bums me out
too like we have bidets now in three
bathrooms at home we're falling out of
control you know you guys can get the
Toshi it's a reasonable one yeah fifty
bucks
not a sponsor it's fucking we bought it
they should but yeah they're fucking
assholes for not sponsoring us but it's
like 70 bucks
it's a fire hose it really is you gotta
really ease into turning it on because
you can get loose with it and it's just
like
it hurts your ass it'll hurt your tender
sweet little asshole and it actually it
actually opened up my asshole when the
water shot in there it actually opened
it a little and made more Brown coming
I've had that too
it's true it does that because you'll be
like I'm done I'm done
yeah and then you're like whoa like
feels like somebody got in there yeah it
does is that what it feels like what
feels like what
having someone go in your ass feels like
go in your ass like what there that is
so nasty yeah seriously be honest they
don't know you dead used to put your
fingers in my butt I like because I feel
like I'm a live show we can we can say a
little more okay you know this is gonna
be downloaded I don't know why I'm just
married to a Triple DES lt
[Applause]
okay can I tell you that honestly since
I had our kid though and and since two
holes became one you know has an
episiotomy yeah so I'm a little nervous
because that hole is not as as taught if
you will as it might be all are my
vision oh you're sweet I appreciate I am
NOT being nice I'm being honest yeah I
have to picture like I have to picture
like eight guys standing behind me just
to try to get in it like I I pretend
it's a competition and they're like yeah
Tom yeah like do it up hurry up whatever
we give it to everyone like it's the
gardener's and it's the fucking what we
have gardeners so how come I get shit
for the Indian guy which is a real thing
because we have Jose he comes by every
fucking Wednesday we're talking about
diet like all right
waynebow Dali what does that mean that
way huevos that's give her eggs give her
eggs this one's fine but this one's the
camera is I don't know what the fuck he
says honestly
is that daddy yankee i think i think you
would know pitbull you have his poster
dolly mr. worldwide you know that dude
it's he's he's ridiculous right yeah he
makes like 35 million easy right just
like giving whales know yeah dolly what
does it mean seriously dolly way but
he's not saying that was I don't know
but I like this Basil's Danny whistles
yeah yeah what is he saying
so what is family saying it
give her come okay
get rid of give her that ball juice yeah
right it's like filming with your guests
Oh Lina the same thing yeah
always come with those guys huh yeah
everywhere savages yeah guys like to
come what do you I mean isn't that crazy
that basically every decision a guy
makes is connected coming are you for
you I mean for me that different yeah
but then but then when guys turn like 50
they become you know human like they you
know I'm saying like your dad became
sweeter and worse to come
yeah look when they need to come goes
down a little like you guys start to
care about helping turtles across the
street I'm sure I think it doesn't
happen at 50 I think you're you got that
wrong maybe like 68 yeah yeah that's
when the tests are like dial down and
you turn into women and you become
people it's great I know I have an uncle
who like just started crying at 75 yeah
I'm like crying it's a sweet moment like
you're a savage dude do you do you think
your dad still comes a lot oh definitely
yeah now cuz he's he has he's friends
with a lot of older like older than him
yeah and he's like you know my buddy
whatever he takes a pill my other buddy
has to inject himself in Jackie's Nick
yeah but he's like you know this guy's
81 this guy's I go oh man like how about
you he's like no not a problem about
like still a lot of letting the pencil
not even your old man's doing fine I'm
like that's enough that's enough
information he's not information about
my dad's dick
so remember when I saw his balls on the
cruise yeah
I still think about it in what way not a
bike hop just like I remember him
flipping his left / now what there it is
yeah you like uncircumcised guys as I
recall right yeah as I recall pretty big
they're low hanger so like you're gonna
have nuts hang low - I hope so
I can only can only dream do you think
about it about having balls that are
sometimes I think about that honestly
not to hit it again but I think about it
on the toilet sometimes you're like
thinking about toilet water yeah yeah
that's real do your bones touch the
water yet no no I mean I have regular
balls they're not no they're they're
really they're good I really like them
come on no I mean it I've all the balls
and I've touched a lot of balls like
Porter did you ever have bad balls yeah
well what were they like bad ball and my
I mean look one woman's bad ball is
another woman's treasure
I don't know right with different
strokes everyone's the same so maybe I
think personally here's my I just don't
I like I'm high and tight I do I like oh
yeah like yours are nice and high and
tight I've had balls that are just all
skin like you're like - so they're too
big and there's not there's nothing in
them those are old balls that's what
that is
I'm never you've been blowing old guys
again
now they're they're young guys like that
huge nuts but I usually usually the
interesting thing tom really
thought-provoking yeah let's get it
going bigger the balls I found that the
shorter and fatter the Weiner like it
would be like a cup bigger the balls
yeah there were short fat wieners
did it affect the the loads they busted
no I'm saying we're the big balls where
you're like Jesus this thing doesn't
turn off where is it like that yeah was
it like that no really I'll be on do you
want to know is it that most yes sure
you I have the most oh yeah yeah no I am
no no I will jerk off with any of you
guys I'm serious this is gross but I'm
gonna do it any cuz whatever yeah I mean
from high school my high school college
girls were always like Jesus yeah what
is up with all this cheese man I know
and I actually asked a doctor about it
once yeah cuz you know you have like men
have like a it's like a contraction
right like yeah I had so I went to the
doctor I was like I was a like 18 19 I
was like look man I'm busting these huge
ass nuts is that normal so I described
it to him in detail and he was like no
it's not normal and then yeah well he
goes that's it's it's you know high much
higher than average but he goes just
consider yourself lucky he said it
though he said it like I've been trying
to come like that for years I dedicated
my life to this and you just get it
naturally and I was like yeah that's
fascinating I know I wonder if the
details what do they get more swimmers
than most no no only has anything to do
it's just the amount of fluid around
yeah I just have a great prostate I go
did you sharpen your knife today you
should know you did take a long shower
it was really long yeah I did rah rah
rah
guys the grossest you know what's fake
all right I'll get to it let's do this I
have a proper show open clip so we'll
play that and then we'll get back to
this in a second important issues here
we go with the important issues of our
show here we go what I'm feeling this is
mine which is for the night just get the
fucking elevator fixed it but it was on
the phone earlier 16 other like lo Utica
New York oh don't bring anyone to this
[Music]
[Applause]
we are live in brass balls Beach Florida
that so that guy was pretty pissed off
yes he's talking to an elevator
manufacturing rep on the phone
I guess his elevator didn't get fixed
when he wanted it to so talking elevator
fixed it it was on the phone earlier
Utica New York did he say the slut I
didn't know that nobody ever says that
like fucking slut that I was talking to
that's so crazy it's a tough call over
the phone - yeah no she's a slide
doesn't yeah but it's it's a good way to
provoke see what happens just a little
bit hey is that slut still there and
then they're like excuse me nobody likes
that
how can all this I mean I guess your
elevator not being fixed does piss you
off yeah this level this level
okay I'm sick of this piece of shit I
have to deal with you people it's a
twist elevator in the world I'm gonna
fire it out and to come in Ram it up
your fucking noses get him here now
Jesus Christ I'd uh you know what I
stands out to me the most about that is
that he will shove it up your noses
right like to be that angry and the
natural inclination be I'll shove up
your fuckin ass that he was like uh-uh
stop that fucking elevator up your nose
it's almost like he pulled his anger in
for a moment right he didn't want to go
blue yeah right that's too far yeah but
it probably would hurt more in your nose
than your ass right what do you think it
would hurt to have an elevator shoved in
any orifice that you have
but yeah your nose you definitely died
yeah sure if I put an elevator app yeah
yeah that hurt so much you know I keep
thinking about the animal lady this week
like some clips stick to me yeah I know
all right
I keep thinking about her and and and
how range warrants rain is that her name
yeah how do you put piss in your but I
can show you you uh because it would
absorb the toxins like you would die
what really stood out to me about her
just lady gave herself a urine enema was
that yeah yeah you know I'm saying she
was so fucking sad to know everybody
rain Florence today I'm going to do a
urine for the first time you should be
like times like like I'm gonna see my
dad for the first time like that
she's so touch she's so touched that
she's committing to this
she's so collected my urine and I just
poured one quart into my enema bucket
you pissed in a bucket is what you're
saying and you're gonna what happens to
you that you get that nutty like how
does that switch flip where you're like
no this is health she's a conspiracy
theorist for sure yeah she is because
III remember one of my down here I went
to high school in Vero Beach if you
don't know I'm right here
and and I had one of my friends my mom's
was like can't trust doctors like though
they'll fuck with you like and like when
you're sick too you know she'll be like
I'm going the doctor she was that stupid
only an idiot would go to the doctor and
then she had all these alternative
therapies which I'm sure like I'm not
saying that there's no alternative
therapy that has you know value but if
you if you keep embracing that only
alternative works then you end up
putting your own piss in your ass you're
gonna die yeah because we wasn't it was
it who's dead the computer gave job yeah
he was alternative therapy he had
pancreatic cancer which is aggressive to
begin with it's not you know high chance
of beating it and they found it early
and so they're like we're gonna take it
out and he was like I may eat fruit
right what he's like I fucking made
these things I'm eating fruit all right
and the doctors like all right he did
make the shit that we're typing on so
and then a few minutes later he was like
I fucked up yeah yeah that is the
equivalent of like I'm gonna get myself
you're an animal
yeah you're right that's what happens
this lady would 100% and they were like
you have a brain tumor we need to
operate Siebel this week and see what
happens okay
so I'm laying on my left side and I'm
just about to insert okay
she is so emotional about this like
she's like
which I understand like again your you
put your own crazy I love crazy loudly :
[Laughter]
now already noticing yeah what do you
notice thing she's laying up again I'm
having a little bit of leakage and I
don't just a little bit I wonder if they
have that you know well if you'd have
that you know I get I just I don't know
how people have on their butts so easily
I mean are you getting used to it you
get used to it
yeah just however I mean I'm sure
there's people in the audience like this
some of our friends are like oh yeah
like you know we bought fuck pretty
regular I'm like what
yeah maybe we're the squares Tom you
know what I mean maybe we should be
giving ourselves pee enemas and yeah
fingering we're talking about two
different things though right what what
fucking regularly and giving yourself a
pee enema yeah but all you have to I
mean shouldn't you give yourself an
enema before you have butt sex just yeah
yeah yeah but the strong performers do
that it's a very strong perfect it's a
courtesy I'm assuming I think it's a
courtesy to yourself man it makes it
easier it's a while I'm gonna open the
clamp over time
[Laughter]
oh sorry to have uh-oh this purple
vision she's tripping out purple vision
toxins in her bloodstream crazy ten
thousand more people coming together and
support me it sounds like trump at a
trump rally or something right like
maybe that's why he has such a big ego
he's like I'm putting pissing my ass
every night people love me I can't say I
can't help it
[Music]
Facebook live and support me see she's
saying her own name now
Florent that's what's going on who's
opening the clamp again oh wow close the
clamp oh my goodness let's just want to
cry
so do I yeah I don't want to watch
thinking about how I can't do it anymore
it's a little bit of a sensation and my
Botox reason region it might just be
because the urine is a little bit cold
that that's not the only reason you're
feeling that way let's move right along
Tom with her okay you brought her up
thinking about her I feel bad she's
crazier he's crazier than catch it okay
so what I have learned about you on this
trip it's very interesting after 12
years of knowing you I feel like I know
almost everything yeah now you are
anorexic yeah you can use I can use
either hand it's true
and what's neat about that talent is
that sometimes I notice you sign with
your left and it looks all retarded like
you'll be all wait what what like you
look stupid when you do it but it's cute
like why do I look stupid it's not right
like you shouldn't you should be right
handed yeah but it got me to thinking
what do you do with either hand which
which hand do you wipe with because I'm
not with you at those times
oh stop prevent I mean all the things
it's like it's automatic like I'm just
good at everything but I do it like the
hand chooses it like through the
anorexia chooses itself
so I write left-handed right looks likes
dumb I brush my teeth
left-handed really yeah I didn't know
that I eat with a fork right know that I
throw a ball right-handed didn't notice
that
and I I prefer to jerk it right-handed
really I can do it with the other hand
but I prefer especially to finish with
the right hand you know there's just
like why is that there's just I know how
to ya know that your your subtle moves
right yeah especially for like that
finishing you know I mean rounding third
I like to go back to there like I can go
left left left leg up and then it goes
to the right hand you know so I do that
and I definitely wipe right-handed yeah
interesting I think higher skill level
things are right-handed
wait a minute but you write with your
left that's quite possibly the highest
skill throw a football man right-handed
okay yeah interesting I shoot
right-handed yeah golf red-handed yeah
not that I do that regularly no you're
not a golfer I didn't know all this
about you these are all new things yeah
I don't know it like I'll tell you a
bunch of stuff if you want to find out
I've also been watching way do you do
everything right-handed
yes everything yeah I have known this is
useless why don't you donate it won't
you do it even when I do Pilates and
stuff the left side is terrible it's
wonky it's weaker I'm totally right
dominant you know yes talent it's just
being strong stuff okay but back to you
so I've noticed this week because we
spent a lot of time together yeah we've
been on vacation here you really savor
your body functions like more than
anybody I know like you'll sneeze like
you do this annoying thing where you
sneeze like three times in a row like
it's clearly for attention by the third
time at you you have to look at the
light to get it out that's the worst I
always look for the light oh yeah and if
you say bless you before I sneeze I'll
knock you the fuck out because it will
fuck with me it makes me so upset when
you're like on the like on the edge
someone's like blast you like fuck you
fuck you I don't know it goes away yeah
cuz you need you need total focus when I
see you doing your that doesn't I don't
feel like that's what I look like
I have to stop and let you do your
retarded face and then you sneeze in
threes and then after you'll be like oh
that was such good sneeze I like how it
feels
don't you like that feeling now right
it's a little it's a little pleasure
it's not like I'm not saying it's like
if you have like a like three or more in
a row and you have that momentary buzz
for me feels good you but you savour
like that you'll be like I was a good
cop or that was a good shit or that was
such a good shit like I don't really
enjoy shooting I just like girly from
you tip like clean way and I'm like oh
god I feel so fucking good right now and
she's like it's cough thing ah what's
well your q-tips look like someone dip
them in orange paint when they didn't
know Jesus Christ yeah we got a lot of
wax is hereditary yeah that's what my
dad told me like all excited I'm like
couldn't it couldn't be a vertical leap
it had to be fucking ear wax sweet it's
Jeff what really cool jeans you got
passed down yeah but you do like them
more than anyone else
yeah it's very cute alright do you want
to go back to this or no listen was this
no you don't like that next elevator guy
alright we're done with elevator guy the
fucking lady
ended it so Christina says I was
listening episode 409 this morning
there's an audio issue 336 an awful
sound filled my headphones and it's you
you sneezing it says
[Applause]
[Music]
you have the fucking balls to talk about
my sleeve the fuck man but that was so
charming it was like a little like a
little dose me at least like a baby
that's hideous
maybe that's why I don't enjoy them
they're not pretty
oh man come I said it affected me
emotionally and still have not recovered
also also at 1508 there was the sound of
what I think was a touched individual
attempting to sing it was deeply
disturbing okay and hope it was just an
equipment issue that can be fixed and
then it says click here to hear it
here's this one yeah okay that's called
a perfect impression I don't know yeah
I'm a huge G&R fan guys
you can't take your headphones off now
can you guys are horrible all of you you
are fucked now no you guys are all
rotten all of you oh you're terrible
you're the worst don't do it again so no
don't do it again don't do it again no
don't do more of things okay okay all
right guys let's get to some ymh
business first of all you know a lot of
people been writing in about this very
important debate that's been raging on
in your mom's house community and that
is whether or not shits push the fart
out Wow yeah very divisive finally
someone is addressing real issues so
this came in from Zachary yeah hey
Hitler
I've been thinking about your god damn
it with the Hitler's every every one of
them start saying oh hey antlers I've
been thinking about your fart and shit
situation and he writes honestly I'm
deeply offended
who are we to apply socially constructed
roles to shits and farts maybe some
farts push-out shits and some shits
push-out farts you excrement normative
binary standards should be cast aside
and we should just accept that farts and
shits are fluid
anyway I hope I hope you can get rid of
your sin or motive constructs and see
the light keep it high and tight Thank
You Zack well thank you wow that's a
really good stuff yeah well that's
really interesting
well did you want to read something
Tommy yeah which one the next one well
no yeah on this topic I'm saying good
job young Jedi
that was it was great I mean no once a
listener brought it to my attention I
was totally blown away yeah you had me
believing fart supposed to shit out for
years that's that's not true because if
farts push this shit out
yeah when shit was done there'd be so
many farts after it's not necessarily so
Tom shits push the farts out right so
then there should be farts at the end of
the shit is what you're saying if are
supposed to shit out but we're going the
other way on it you don't even
understand this this is high-level stuff
right philosophically speaking well I
had I had an epiphany on this very topic
as we've been spending time here in Palm
Beach is that I farted the other day and
I kept farting and farting and farting
and farting with no shit okay and I
thought to myself I thought to myself
can't we have farts for the sake of
having them why must all farts have
purpose or utility now you weren't
really philosophical thank you yeah I
mean it's like this capitalistic notion
that everything has to have a fucking
utility attached to it you really did
what if farts are just for farts sake
like art first etic enjoyment there's no
usefulness to them yeah you're opening
my whole mind up again yes I
[Laughter]
it was super deep bro thanks guys
here's a thought provoker it's also foul
it says sub kane I was sitting in bed
after a night at the bars and my
girlfriend was vomiting in the bathroom
right next to my bedroom after one too
many adult beverages nope that's when
something amazing happened at the same
moment while she barked and made a sound
only Christians that could love she
farted which raises the question what do
you call it when you puke and fart at
the same time keep it high and tight and
paulien by sincerely hot cocoa whoa
what do you have a name for that no that
is a thought provoker you can flirt puke
and fart I feel like those two go
hand-in-hand food poisoning yep and if
you barf and far it could be a Bart I
guess I would just call it a Burt and
leave it at that
yeah well done Tom yeah yeah I think
you're right let's leave it at that
yep here's another thought provoker that
came in I really like this one okay are
you ready guys this is from Gerald he
writes can retarded people vote whoa
that's such a good question like it's
mean and you go like come on but then
like a few seconds later you're like
that's a good question
like right right the answer is yes wait
how do you know wait wait what about
retarded people voting uh-huh he was
voting yeah cuz they can't be like dude
not you like you can't you go to vote
and they're like no no no no no really I
can't
no that's true someone helped him well
now wait a minute that's a physical
disability but he was mentally disabled
as well okay yeah but what if he was
like you know you know like what have
you seen you're like this guy doesn't
know what day it is
you know like I'm serious like can that
guy he cannot how do you know this
though what you were
what turning and return I wonder I
wonder couldn't can retard it they can't
drive clearly they can drive yes they
can we learned that as long as you can
pass the driving test you can show up
fucking drooling and know it's true and
if you pass the test they're like you
passed the test
like but I'm saying for voting it's your
it's your constitutional right you're 18
that's the only two prerequisite I think
you would have to be just beyond like
literally no you know like like if you
can't find your way in the booth then
baby they can go like you definitely
can't but if you're like I like what
what that's not crazy I'm an actor so
I'm so okay I'd go retarded yeah let's
see this one okay Hitler god damn it
they're all it's a lot do you guys think
deaf people are more grossed out by
farts than non deaf people that's a good
question though I look at it like this
their other senses are heightened just
like blind people including the smells
but add into the mix they can't hear
them a silent but deadly is always worse
because it sneaks up on you basically
their whole life is nothing but silent
but deadly
[Applause]
that's from Kevin Kevin you're a goddamn
Rhodes scholar and that is true cuz
every time if someone could it could be
like super loud and you'd be like what
the fuck man yeah you well they just
kick you it's the warning so you can
brace right off so when you know the
expectation is met then you know that's
true yeah it's always a surprise yeah
let's talk about death so Jerry Lewis
died yes he was Kristina's not a fan he
was speaking of retarded that was his
whole thing that is true his whole thing
was acting retarded funny retarded he
basically locked down retarded I mean
that is that is this is him that's Jerry
Lewis if you didn't know and he died and
they did this thing The Hollywood
Reporter which is it's really big in in
LA that the trades right like the
industry news and Hollywood Reporter's
definitely one of the biggest they did a
special interview where they were
interviewing people that are still
working in Hollywood over 90 years old
why and because this just to be like
well that's what they wanted to know
they're like why are you doing it stop
and just relax but I mean they were also
celebrating them you know they're like
your oldest fuck you're still
entertaining people it's pretty you know
it's probably it's a cool thing
Hollywood Reporter calls you you work in
Hollywood it's a big deal they go to his
house he allows them into his house they
set up for a an interview that's going
to be in print but also it to air online
and he was such a dick and it's it's
kind of hilarious but like he just was
like it's like why would you even say
yes to the interview that's the thing is
that he had he was notorious they'd show
up they were like you want to do any of
you now
you know no and he had a bad reputation
for being really grumpy towards the end
of his life yeah though this is pretty
funny this is pretty good we're doing a
feature on people who are still working
in their 90's have you ever thought
about retiring why it was there never a
moment that you thought it might be time
to retire you would why
so that imagine being the interview and
be like oh my god like you come from you
come from a generation a little older
and I think a Bob Hope
George Bert I like that he tells a 91
year old yeah you come from a generation
a little older ya know Shannara people
you knew many of whom didn't want to or
never retired either you see
similarities with them none none what do
you think drives people like you and
then because we do it well wait this is
even better this this is great huh
what's different about performing now
for you than say 20 years ago how is it
how is it different for you isn't what
an inspiring interview huh
it is hey how do you keep the materials
fresh sessions to being you know older
and your your performing or does it how
do you keep the material fresh for
yourself by working at it so then if
you're this guy you're like oh my god so
then he goes like cuz your honor you're
basically willing him to just talk more
not give you one word answer so he's
like well here's one
I know factually hat you'll have to give
me therefore answer he's asking guests
um how was Vegas different now than when
you started working there 50-plus years
ago right a million which is I was Vegas
totally different when you first came
here what was the first time you you
performed in Vegas 1947 sorry 70s way
like
first showed up it's not it's the same
exactly the same exactly the same there
were two hotels you lying dick he's so
dismissive why do the interview if
you're not even gonna answer the guy
it's so weird how would you describe the
place doesn't even show up in 1947 what
was it I wasn't a little bit of a dusty
cow town it was what was it what was it
like dusty cow town well thanks for the
interview Jerri here's a supercut of his
answer why why none because we do it
well it is not at all by working at it
anyone that's 90 does no no 1947 it's
not it's the same exactly the same
dusted cow town no no you asshole I have
to admit I think that's the funniest
shit he's everything absolutely I feel
like at 91 I would give the same
interview you know well that's the thing
is I once your face starts melting off
of your skull you know what I mean like
that's when you go behind closed doors
and just retire yeah you know just just
give it up your ego and the guy is such
a fucking egocentric yeah wait torturing
people with your existence at that point
just go away and die like the rest of us
oh my god
I'm sorry is that too dark how do you
know where blue jeans came from during
the 1950's young America discovered blue
jeans and the industry exploded in the
United States it's a hidden puke clip I
had you looking over here boom oh that
fucking hurt
that was mean that really hurt actually
[Music]
you're terrible alright here's another
thought provoker there's no more barf
clips when food goes right through you
is it the meal you just ate or a prior
one being pushed out that's a good
question I don't see how it could be the
meal you just ate it can't be but it
feels like you yeah but maybe it's
pushing the bad food out that you had
earlier and that's what's cleaning you
out right yes the meal that was in you I
mean you're getting into medical stuff
yeah yeah it's making space well that's
what it is
stomachs like fucking your hand yeah you
also knew the retarded question towns
the fucking expert of West Palm Beach
huh you want to do a master of accents
yeah okay so this came in let's see what
this is here this is a I have like a
fucking goddamn gnat all right so this
is Scottish whoa boy that's a toughy
this couple is on the Jeremy Kyle show
confronting each other about cheating oh
all right let's see if you guys can
figure out what's baby nice English just
so you know no that's all good nigga on
you see Stephen you finally got the boy
Steve might take a glass - it's not that
sounded like I know what you thought it
was good n-word no no no sounds like
it's clear I thought I'd be receiving
just ideal obviously and you know what's
the point
I heard you know what yeah and she said
it's clear she said it's clear she
definitely said it's people up it's
clear something definitely a thought I'm
receiving she's idea obviously and you
know obviously she said obviously Oh
honestly okay fucking show-offs and then
and then here's okay so so crazy let's
go back to the one where everyone
thought they heard something because I
have I have the clip here okay you so I
know it okay here we go okay here we go
and go ahead what's all good nigga and
you see Steven you finally got the boy
Steve might take a quarter you buy
enough to glasses that's good like you
did so that by the way at the beginning
is she saying you did she's saying you
did it's how heavy this boy Jackson is
good that's you did no good and then oh
man but that's all good nigga on you see
Steven you fainted boys she's saying the
n-word conversation so now you're going
to say see when you finally get the
balls to admit it you're going to say
one or two lassies that's what the whole
thing it that's what she says I swear
dude yes it is she's racist bad wait
that's all good nigga corn you see
Steven you finally got the boy Steve
might take a quote you say buy enough to
lassies I heard that's what she says
somebody here Scottish
[Music]
do you not think she's saying that you
think the translations wrong I
she says the N word conversation no she
doesn't
no I'm sure the translations accurate I
just don't you know that's crazy that's
crazy that that is Englishman that's
English damn that is that is English
when I say he says when I slept with
someone else I he does he says when I
slept with someone else I told her when
she did it she lied for a year and a
half that's what that's right here when
I say these are our fucking brothers and
sisters guys yep all right that was a
horrific failure that was bad all right
you know what I've been noticing on this
vacation dad's they at the poppy sorry I
mean they there is a specific there is a
specific type of vacation dad I've been
seeing where they they're always
shirtless right in their box or whatever
swim trunks
uh-huh and then they have the hard booze
belly there's that guy but then dad bod
right it's hard but then I saw they have
like a rib the ribcage shows and the fat
belly which I feel like it should be
either/or but not both it's a good
observation how do you have a fat belly
and the rib cage that's stage three
cancer actually that's a no that's
that's totality oh my god
prominences how many of you did that
guy's voice during the flips I was so
fun it was great right we did it the
whole time totality he was so excited
about it yeah totality
that was the best yeah that was great
love that they do that dad prominences
that's hard to achieve this you got to
go hard for years to get that that
special iPod yeah for where the ribs and
the big heart who she that's just rough
man you gotta like really blues it up
definitely six days a week and and like
you still somehow stay active so you
have the hard got the ribs on the side
it's a Florida bod it's a Florida
totally and what I've noticed is on
every Beach whether it's it's like a
Florida Keys bod yeah but I noticed like
in South Beach or here there's always
the guy who looks like a piece of
fucking beef jerky skinny skinny skinny
guy with his dog ribs showing yeah
leather skin yeah like charcoal yeah
that is a Florida guide to its side
Florida guy but then they're they're
they're athletic like they run all day
or something like what are you doing you
just want to die the Sun worshipers man
you know what else is it you see it in
the South you were pointing out you're
like look how this dipshit is dressed
see I'm used to seeing this from growing
up here but so we're at the hotel and
this guy has on like like pink khaki
style you know like pink shorts with a
belt and then a tucked in button-down
collar like he looks like a like a frat
like an artist
going to the game it's a douche bag and
she's like what the fuck is that guy
wearing and I go oh yeah that's a that's
like a it's like the the southern preppy
look you know I mean
yeah yeah I hate him so much - and she's
like who dresses like that I'm like like
18 million people well because like
because seriously in LA if I saw fucking
dude wearing like pink pink khaki shorts
a brown braided belt and then like a
polo ya collar and then tan top ciders
with no socks I know you'd be like this
dude's about to get beat to death right
that motherfucker will be dead no way
you would survive but it's like
automatic right you see that guy doesn't
even blink when you see that guy you're
like that guy but you know he's like a
preppy douchebag got the Brooks Brothers
look you're gonna like the way you look
no s Men's Wearhouse you're gonna like
the way you look Brooks Brothers well
what's Brooks bright like I love how
much you don't know that I have no
capacity for you know I don't fuckin
care that Brooks brother that is some
southern shit though we don't have that
in LA no fuckin way what a guy where
like a lime tuxedo why does that cause
seersucker suit oh that's super southern
[Music]
Georgia
yeah Carolina's racist places right yeah
it's like it's an outfit and I might be
racist right the plantation yeah you get
the suit you get the tiki torch you're
ready to go now got the whole outfit man
biggie torch right those guys were
prepped out they were like collared
shirts they went to Brooks Brothers yeah
they did and they're like I like the way
I look I'm gonna go out
you're smart but all sales are fine
should we do ours are special oh yeah
yeah also you want to get that twin
thing came in we've been really asking
great questions about twin dicks yeah
are there any twins here no twins it's
like almost 500 people I'm sorry like
you represent the twins that aren't here
they didn't want to come this these guys
are actually twins and they're talking
about it he couldn't get his size she
was too tight yeah until you stepped in
yeah mom keep a smaller penis is that
way I didn't understand that they're
twins so but here's what the guy says
this is what he gets - so this lady's
interviewing these two twins one of them
basically says that you know a guy had
trouble with the girl she was with and
then he explained it was they were
friends I thought it was like you
couldn't fit in size so we called you in
because you have a narrower penis Meuse
like it's okay we got everything is to
say everything is identical everything
is identical so that's another eyebrows
a case that their dicks are the same
exactly the same I'm beginning to lean
towards that solution to this thought
provoker yeah yeah yeah I mean it's it's
compelling shit ABC's gonna do a profile
next week there all right let's do some
I joined you fill er up yeah sure okay
let's do it
we need our CEO okay here we go special
scene
[Music]
okay so for fill er up sealer shut we're
doing today hey your mom's house edition
of fill er up sealer shut meaning that
we're going to discuss people that have
been featured on the show so first first
we have the ladies okay so would you
rather fill up and seal shut rain
Florence
today okay today we know her now okay so
you know who that is
or would you rather fill up and sale
shut calm down later for bhutesu I think
we've spoken the tribe has spoken
but if I have to choose I mean I cannot
really think about it they know I am I
am here's a rain Florence she's gonna be
all weird and oh she's gonna cry yeah
yeah that's true she's filled up with
piss I feel like the MU soup lady is a
real PID and like she is a savage yeah
yeah like rains gonna be like I want you
to connect with me yeah she's gonna cry
and feel I'm ready to make and musu play
DS gonna be like fucking just slam it in
there don't give a shit
mu soup lady would take your head and
just force it in between our legs
yep and you're under layer four moon
suit and you'd have to you'd have to eat
her box she won't let you out
oMG you'd have to eat all her mu soup
oh man I'm gonna go I bet I bet at least
if you were eating her out she'd be
super a complimentary you know the moo
shu back you guys are doing good yeah
she be so much fun I feel like the MU
soup ladies a party
yeah rain is like a serious bummer it'd
be a downer yeah I'm almost but it
actually depends what mood you're in if
you want to get fucking wild you go
moose soup all the way yeah if you want
to like really take your if you want to
have like an emotional connection then
rain is like you know just depends what
you like let's ask the audience who here
would rather make sweet love multiple
times to rain Florence the urine therapy
lady few in the back who would take to
the moose soup lady wow you guys are
fuckin pigs you guys are doing good holy
shit okay
so now we have this other one okay no
yeah now it's the men because I'm
definitely I'm with them I'm going moose
ooh this is a party yeah because also
you know she drinks you just like just
give me a handle of whiskey and I'll
fucking do it you just get through it
she's a serious Pig okay so here are
your guys like it's guys and I've been
featured on this podcast so it's not
gonna be good so would you rather fuck
but you would rather have be filled up
and sealed shut by this man rah rah
never who is a master of sharpening his
sword 50 times 50 times or would you
rather have sex with this man it's not
gonna be I mean close your eyes close
your eyes close your eyes close your
eyes all right so there's kisses kisses
on your neck oh he makes that noise from
a fucking highway imagine
if he's up inside you just pumping over
and over here's the thing the rub rub
guy is so fucking creepy
I can't even what I'm so not in he's a
master of love me I know you you I that
doesn't but doesn't matter here's why I
don't like him he'll take longer because
he's mastered his his circumstances how
do you say masada tesak oh we found old
videos of him like I don't know 30 plus
years old still he was talking about
your dick and your balls then like he is
he hasn't wavered at all man when you
finish the kidney Masada tesak oh okay
tastico is incredible factory producing
a law of sexual energy this is from the
I mean it's a really interesting one to
think about so you have a guy who for 50
years he's just been like touching his
dick talking about his dick talking
about sex so I maybe be like the most
mind-blowing sexual experience you could
ever know why he's such an expert I mean
woman to woman like the all these
scenarios are about getting in and
getting out right so my mind it's like
I'm gonna get in there and I'm gonna let
the trans-canada dad he's gonna be so
stoked dude he's never had a mouth on
his penis ever this will be the first
time any woman's ever tugged his nuts
and he's gonna love it
and I'm gonna make this guy's life dude
the trans-canada highway okay that's how
you see it too yeah but what about
that's the thing in this scenario what's
supposed to be happening is these guys
are going to town for like hours so you
can't really think of it as in and out
maybe she's got a good point
wait hold on the lady in the front just
said the rub rub guy is going to be
counting out like 100 but so you're
gonna have to hear this asshole count
that was racist the way you did that I
was doing an impression yeah fifty time
and then he'll go fifty time fifty time
what's the time like you know turn but
as a woman you can just close your eyes
and lay your scenario what you're saying
makes sense if you're like the idea is
to get in and out but what if in this
scenario that we're proposing yeah you
have to spend an hour with the person
would you rather have the rub rub guy
who's like I make you come fast hog hug
or
or it's TransCanada that guy it's it's
burned out yes you know why because I'll
give him a thimble full of whiskey which
he's never had in his life and he'll go
crazy like this is crazy and it'll be
it'll be so much fun for him I would do
it for him I would fuck the rub rub down
dude that guy's gonna open your mind up
you big I've never even felt that in my
balls before and I hate be like I know
I'm a fucking I'm the master I'm the rub
rub all right let's take a poll who here
is gonna go for the rub rub guy yes a
hundred percent okay okay what about the
trans-canada highway thank you
give me my reward thank you
where is that from give me my reward
give me my reward porn - come - come
[Music]
oh okay
[Applause]
[Music]
all right I'll say this before we get
started with would you rather you have a
gift for these you really do you've come
up with some of the best ones ever thank
you like that it's amazing yeah it's
because I understand suffering and not
know I I feel like I I feel like I like
what is misery the would you rather
champ thank you guys please let's go
okay
okay would you rather yeah I like would
you rather wear a fart helmet
what's a fart helmet it's my own design
so a fart helmet is it's a tube that's
hooked up to your butthole and then it's
connected to like a space helmet like
what you wear like a mask yeah so a fart
mask oh they did okay so but every fart
it's in your face and you're smelling it
all day are you smelling your own farts
all day all day or or you pee in a mason
jar but you carry it with you everywhere
and you're like you have to you have to
talk about not to talk about it so like
you meet people you're like this is my
urine I believe in keeping all of it I
can get you a jar if you would like and
introduce you to the lifestyle right or
just smell your own fart with a mask on
right do you realize that like as crazy
as you look to people when you're like
this is my urine if you walk into the
bank with your fart mask on it's just
there pressing the button under the desk
immediately right right well then that's
what I'm saying is that either scenario
it's a life ruiner no they definitely
ruin your life yeah that's with these I
just think about what will be the most
horrible shit in the world yeah like a
fart helmet it's gonna
masks great it's hard to perform it's
hard to card to prepare your stand-up
career is over like you can't call the
club make sure you have the mic inside
my mask so I don't miss any farts while
I'm up there
no they won't they won't hook you up
with that yeah but you could put your
urine mason jar down well then that
disqualifies you from a lot like imagine
having a new Conan and then you're like
[Laughter]
what's that we'll be right back it's
like well interesting you should ask
it's pretty awful but I still think you
have some chance you know like some
people would not notice your mason jar
some people would be like okay and kind
of you know I mean kind of move move on
I think you have to go mason jar a fart
mask is 100% you got you should have
tinfoil on your head too like you you
can't no one's gonna talk to you but you
say helmet but you're describing a mask
it's over your your face is concealed
and then when people are like are you
scared or but the apocalypse you like
noir huh
I have a fart tube going from the my ass
to my mouth and they're like I'll see
you later he's walking away yeah so 100%
mason jar take the mason jar to its
happen exactly you have a story and then
they're like absolutely the essence of
it is you have to tell people like I've
decided to do this thing I collect my
urine yeah you have to that's the
craziness and then I go have you ever
read a a urine enema and then they're
like you have to you have to preach the
gospel the exits over there if you don't
mind yeah
all right what do you got I'm gonna take
I'm gonna take the mason jar mason jar
okay clap for you what's a mason jar
[Applause]
and they sparked helmet wow there's some
nasty-ass girls in the crowd how could
you what you like your own brand but
your job is over there's no way your
boss is like it's cool you work from
home do you have are you in a
relationship you're married you're here
are you single what yeah it's yeah that
could be your career if you're like I
wear my mask you sure you could
incorporate this into your website and
now you're making even more money you
just said that so sincerely yeah I know
well now I was thinking like she's
thinking you're working from home now
you've got fart helmet mister Escom it's
fucking brilliant dude it becomes a
lifestyle it's a brand okay yeah
alright next moving along here's my
second one okay okay okay would you
rather would you rather be vegan but
you're one of those vegans that you have
to fucking talk about it 24/7 that's
what they do
yes I wanted to be respectful I'm sure
there's a few that are not proselytizers
but you're the annoying kind okay right
and you're constantly proselytizing
every time someone is with you I hope
those shoes are leather and so you can
vagina right and you talk about your
smoothies all the time like bees are
suffering when you eat honey and yeah
yeah and you're one of those annoying
people it doesn't need anything on the
menu so when we go out you're always
like is there dairy in that it's that
lactose freeze that gluten-free is a so
like all-you-can-eat is like five things
you're a pain you sound like you're a
real fucking fun guy okay or you have to
listen to me whistle constantly 100%
cutting a meat out of my life
Hanukkah side I fucking hate whistle
whistle for them whistle for them
it's terrible
no I'm already listen no I'm not having
any dairy tomorrow I'm not no now that
was terrible I don't I
that would be rough though I mean what
you're proposing is really difficult
that's terrible I would eat there i
annoy the shit out of you or you annoy
the shit out of everybody that's yes
I would miss that food for sure that's
what's fucked up but yeah but hearing
you yeah there's the thing is it's not
the her whistle is bad it's that it
would be constant it would be yeah but
when even when I hear the world-class
whistlers I'm still like well you'd
knock that shit off please yeah it's
horrible I hate when people do it
indoors
you know like waiting in line at the
bank and the guys like you're like are
you fucking serious right now he's
asserting dominance that's what they're
doing
yes their territory it is a
psychological reason starting there this
is my territory has to fucking listen to
me whistle dish fuck I hate them I think
you would rather fucking go vegan they
listen to you hoping I would be a real
asshole would rather listen to Christina
whistle all day every day and who would
rather go vegan and listen to her way so
it's kind of close okay yeah okay I've
gotten one last one okay this is this is
more gross would you rather never floss
you're done flossing some of you pigs
aren't doing it already okay yeah
or when you dump you're only allowed to
wipe once the conscious person Wow Wow
heated debate in here look this feels
like like a period piece yeah they're
like we're gonna allow women in the
workforce then and everybody's like
what's going on that was such a sincere
reaction I know I'm like whoa lady whoa
take a big stinky shit after I go I
don't use 25 plus the toilet I dip my
hand I get in here three rub clean and
flush again one two three four five he's
nasty as hell one white eye your dude
you'd be yeah these are great questions
okay
yes order order here here Jana I submit
to the court that in this particular
scenario we are dealing with bday les
toilettes
[Applause]
[Laughter]
order goddamn it order is absolutely
brilliant would you rather you will
entertain these thoughts this Triple D
slut wife has a point the reason I
choose a bidet less toilet is because
this is the everyman scenario hold on
hold on hold on what you what you
propose is so absurd not if I actually
forgot what the other option is what in
the hell was the other other no flossing
no flossing no you are you are 5150 if
you choose one wipe over not flossing
again are you out of your guy hold on
I'm gonna revise it in the moment
because I feel there's a better option
than the flossing would you rather have
one wipe yes or not wash your hands for
a year and that's a better would you
rather
you could do that you could do that
again you would be hey there's that
fucking psycho that wears gloves
everywhere but it's better than being
like hey here's that guy that smells
like fucking piles of shit because he
listens to a podcast now Jana Jana yes a
way around such a conundrum of the one
WAP is to take a shower every time you
make a bowel movement that's the way
that's the that's the workaround if you
will appeal denied that is not
acceptable that is not acceptable so oh
no no this is this is not Alison if you
do the one wipe okay this is you can
wash your hands as much as you like now
that's the caveat so you can one
meaningful wipe goes a long way hey
there are some shits I take that only
require one way now get the fuck out
here what are you thinking Tom I mean if
you don't wash your hands for a year
yeah you're fucked in a lot of ways I
mean you really are think about all the
time oh that's not crazy I'm taking a
shower
[Laughter]
this is your rain this gentleman you
bring up a valid point what's the point
wait what do you do to work okay you may
put plastic baggies over your hands in
the shower okay till to wash it look you
ever have a cast on your arm and you
have to cover it yeah you can do that
what sweetie
again here you there's there's there's
that's what the Supreme Court would hear
what is it how are you gonna wash your
asshole if you can't get your hands no
no easily okay I cover them in plaque
I cover them in plastic baggies they're
air types it's so serious and you all
have a washcloth which I'm opposed to
using in regular life but because of
this thing I have to and I washcloth my
asshole easy-peasy dude ya fuckin loofah
that shit dude no plastic bags no no
yeah yeah that's true
oh there you go you're suggesting what a
fucking would you rather I mean this is
Charlottesville all over again
this is crazy very divisive issue very
device using hand wash races and washing
or one wipe top it goes one Tom what's
your answer final answer we need it I
think I think one wipe calm yeah I think
I would definitely I would be the gnarly
hands dude I would just walk around with
unwashed hands I cannot be one wipe guy
you've got to be kidding me
there would be times there would be
times when you're like I I just can't
jump in the shower and you could not I
could not go through life like why you
shrugging like whatever because there
there are many one white but you can
shower after so that's why I'm saying no
what's that
see sure what what happens to demolition
he scoops with that all right this is
getting haven't seen in years
all right look look at all the fucking
alright let's fucking take a vote
yeah let's think about okay who votes
for the know hand-washing for a one-year
go ahead clap
[Applause]
[Laughter]
who votes for one wipe dumps do you hear
that sounded like that sounded like more
women did the one wipe dump I think is
our shits are not as gnarly
no but look that's but it's so fun that
that you guys came out tonight and we
love we absolutely tell people it's all
the time we love doing the podcast it's
the it's our favorite thing that we do
so thank you very much oh yeah
we're gonna be out there anybody that
wants to meet anybody wants a picture I
brought and if you wanna share it or
whatever we got that if not we're fuckin
whatever will be I need to take a whiz
so give me a second all right we'll see
you thank you guys for coming out
tonight appreciate it
[Music]
you know that feeling when you have to
go you have to squeeze your cheeks
together you have to stretch your leg
[Music]
you know it was really messy really get
your bus in one of what you could go and
get different guys to jizz
[Music]